let's bring in Harold Reynolds what was
Harold's a career average he strikes me
as about a 260 Harold Reynolds Major
League Baseball Network analyst Harold
your career batting average was I got
you I got you to see you tried to round
it off you were gonna take the 260
weren't change our Major League Baseball
Network post season starts tomorrow and
Harold can be seen on MLB tonight
Major League Baseball network throughout
the postseason I'd set the scene what's
at stake today and tonight
internationally nationally so Brewers
I'm gonna get this right if you're the
Rockies the plan in LA yeah and if you
lose you're gonna be possibly hosting a
wild card game anyway
a big key come down to the bullpen not
the way I look at that game the Brewers
are gonna have to be a team they want
advanced to the playoffs
this is strength of their bullpen the
Cubs will be the starting rotation so I
think the Brewers are more of a muscle
in today then the Cubs so Brewers Lee
Brewers Cubs for the Central Division
title loser plays in the wild-card game
Tuesday Rockies Dodgers for the National
League West title loser plays Tuesday in
the national ink logged card game Walker
Buehler might be the hottest pitcher in
the National League
I just think of stuff as a left
can dominate a game and so I'm looking
at the Dodgers won in that game I also
sold this Joe Mauer Joe Mauer still
playing baseball and well he did
yesterday he's been around for 15 years
so he finishes probably his career
batting 306 didn't have a thousand RBIs
had a hundred and forty three home runs
but six-time all-star he won the MVP
Silver Slugger five times he won three
gold Gloves the only here's a good
trivia question the only American league
catcher to ever win a batting title and
he won three the twins made the playoffs
four times in his career you know that
probably hurts him you know if you're
winning a couple of World Series then
maybe you're gonna get more love from
the hole I don't know if Joe Mauer is a
Hall of Famer or not what do you make of
those numbers with Joe Mauer is he a
Hall of Famer yeah he stayed at catcher
I think he's a lock to be a
hall-of-famer but really compiled a lot
of numbers in the last what eight nine
years he didn't catch that much so I
think he falls short I really do
alright MVP in National League is it
Yelich I've been sad Javy Baez all year
just because he affects so many games
defensively as well as offensively I
mean you look at he's got over 30 homers
over 100 RBIs he's done it wiring a wire
he always really carried the second half
but I looked up yesterday and Yelich was
like 2 RBIs and a home run short of the
Triple Crown that's how well he's played
you know I think it's going to be a coin
toss I pick Javy Baez but I think most
we're gonna pick Yelich yeah I agree we
would you with Baez but I think that
Yelich wanted here in the last three
weeks
not that Baez lost it but I think he'll
be you're a nationally MVP American
League MVP yeah JD Martinez flirt with
the Triple Crown but it feels like it's
mookie betts is MVP yeah that's a tough
one too and for the first time we really
had some great races all the way to the
finish with good guys that were carrying
their teams and I think that's what's
been missing the last few years
that's kind of minimized the importance
of a playoff run and a pennant run and
being on a contender for those type of
awards like you look at Messiah degrom
that's gonna be degrom and he has nine
wins and he's on a team that wasn't even
close to being in the playoffs but
that's kind of where the riders have
gone so it's good to see you got it that
were in the race for me anyway when you
start talking about those big awards I
was also wondering about this that the
Dodgers thought that you were gonna have
max scherzer pitch and then it felt like
he was announced that he was going to be
pitching and then all of a sudden Max
Scherzer is not pitching what did you
make of that from like the Dodgers
perspective yeah I wanted Max Scherzer
pitching he said it on Friday you know
so if he doesn't say it on Friday he
basically said if the game is important
on Sunday I'm taking the ball and I'm
pitching yeah when you say that then go
do it but then I heard word that they
had told the Rockies last week that Max
Scherzer was not going to pitch so I
don't know I missed that the other one
from me Dan that kind of got me was the
Cardinals are playing the Cubs yesterday
and yadi Molina and the sunna both don't
play and I'm sitting there going you got
all winter to rest and had the Cardinals
been the game meant something yesterday
they have both played and I just think
when yadi makes that big of a difference
to a pitching staff I would love to see
him catch for Jack Flaherty yesterday
and see what the Cardinals might have
done to affect the Cubs so I don't know
I just think those things are part of
the integrity of the game as you go down
the stretch we play 162 in this case
today not 163 but the game doesn't quit
at 161 I think we should have let those
guys compete good to visit with the HR
will be watching during the postseason
we'll check in with you thanks for
joining us Harold Reynolds Major League
Baseball Network analyst and all the
postseason action you can get their
coverage pre and post for the postseason
on MLB Network there for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience
2:39 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show ass
[Music]